beef wellington has to be the ultimate
indulgence one of my all-time favorite
main courses and it would definitely be
on my last supper menu my version is a
lot lighter and sexier and for christmas
i'm going to give it an added twist
first off the fillet of beef
now look at it it's beautiful first the
most important part is to sear it salt
pepper the fillet is the leanest and the
most expensive cut of beef it comes from
underneath the lower backbone a part of
the animal which has very little muscle
and this is what makes it such a tender
cut
very very hot pan
olive oil and literally roll it around
the pan
we're not cooking the beef we're just
searing it which will really help
to give another layer of flavor and beef
in
lovely now use the side of the pan so
the beef
sears down the back when you tilt it
it's a secret to get it done quickly it
gives that really nice roasted flavor
delicious once you've got the colour
very carefully lift up the beef
and see it on top
and sear it on the bottom
out
and onto the plate
english mustard
what this does now
it gives it a bit of sort of bit of heat
just lightly brush
the mustard
over the beef
so really important that you do this
as the beef comes straight out of the
pan
as the beef starts to cool down it
absorbs all that heat from the mustard
horseradish is a really nice alternative
as well just leave that to sit
and relax as the fillet rests prepare
the filling which is called a duck sale
put 700 grams of chestnut mushrooms into
a blender
add a chopped clove of garlic
season with salt and pepper
and blitz
[Music]
christmas wouldn't be christmas without
chestnuts and just crumble them in
to the mushrooms
the chestnut sweet nutty flavor works
brilliantly with the earthy taste of the
mushrooms and because they contain more
starch and less oil than other nuts they
have a much softer texture that is
perfect for the filling
that smells amazing
smells like christmas
once the mixture is finely chopped cook
in a hot dry pan this removes the water
from the mushrooms and intensifies the
flavour
[Music]
you can see the water coming out
instantly
[Music]
such an essential stage really critical
to the success of the wellington that
you dry those mushrooms out and get rid
of all that water
take the mushrooms up even further some
fresh thyme in there which will make it
really nice and light and fragrant
when all the water's been fried off
remove from the pan and leave to cool
then start assembling the wellington
stage one
wrapping the beef fillet first of all
these wonderful slices
of parma ham and look
beautiful
overlap it
and set it there
so the secret of overlapping the palmer
ham
is to make sure
it contains all those juices
coming out of the beef
in the traditional recipe for beef
wellington a thick chive and spring
onion pancake is used instead of ham but
the parmesan makes the dish much lighter
and its sweet salty flavor really
complements the mushroom and chestnut
filling
a little touch of pepper no salt because
the ham is naturally salty just a little
twist
of pepper
and then from there your mushrooms
and basically
mushrooms go on
use the back of the spoon to spread them
nice and thinly
half an inch from the ends
rump holes
no hop it every time there's meat
now he comes
next lay the beef
on top
and very carefully
fold that over
now
we're going to lift that up and wrap
the beef
nice and carefully so all that mushroom
and parmesan
is encasing the beef all the way over
push it nice and tight
roll it nice and tight
and go all the way over
now
the secret from here
is to really let the clint film do the
work
just nip it at the ends
and squeeze
and what we're doing is just creating
this wonderful sort of cylinder shape
off
and then just twist it
nice and tightly and the tighter is the
more perfect the shape then place in the
fridge for 15 minutes to firm up
[Music]
once it's set it's ready for the final
wrap a little bit of tim film
puff pastry
beef
now
very carefully
first roll the puff pastry over the beef
until the two edges meet
then trim off any excess pastry
and twist the ends together to ensure
the beef is completely sealed in its
pastry case
to set that perfectly
and get it really nice and firm to make
it really cylinder type
clip them over
[Music]
and just pull that nice and tight
but the big secret behind this is that
it can be done the night before and the
tighter the clint film the better the
shape
the more even the shape
the more evil it cooks
put it back in the fridge for five
minutes to fill up again
then take off the tim film
always like the perfect christmas
cracker
to give the pastry a lovely rich golden
brown color when it bakes brush it with
egg yolk
and then finally you don't have to do
this but it's a chefy thing a little bit
decoration back of the knife down
and then just twist
and mark the pastry when it comes out of
the oven
it's got that wow factor
add a generous sprinkle of salt to
ensure the pastry becomes lovely and
crisp then bake in an oven at 200
degrees for around 35 minutes depending
on how rare you like your beef
once out of the oven it's crucial you
let the wellington rest for at least 10
minutes this allows the meat to relax
and reabsorb its delicious juices making
sure it's tender and succulent nice and
gently
hear that pastry how crisp that is this
is the bit we've been waiting for
oh wow
my god
i'm in heaven and for me
if you want a really nice change to
roast turkey
this
has to be the ultimate for the table it
smells christmassy the chestnuts the
mushrooms and that nice crisp pastry on
the outside
look at it
i'm ready to die and go to heaven
[Applause]
[Music]
you